y en nuestra sección de economía
volvemos con nuestro periodista
especializado Juan Pablo lucumín Juan
Pablo Buenos días de nuevo y hablemos de
una protesta que se realiza en el centro
de Inglaterra María Clara Buenos días
nuevamente es exactamente en Coventry
Inglaterra donde los trabajadores de un
almacén de Amazon llamaron a huelga este
miércoles pidiendo un incremento
salarial y el hecho se consagra como la
primera vez que Amazon se enfrenta a un
paro en sus operaciones en Reino Unido
con unos 300 empleados llamados a huelga
Bueno y qué están pidiendo ellos y qué
responde la empresa eso es lo que
revisaremos que piden pero también
porque lo están pidiendo y ya vamos a
revisar por ejemplo Ellos están
recibiendo más bien ya recibieron un
incremento del 5% en su salario están
pidiendo un aumento del 50% La Brecha es
altísima y el promedio Pues de aumento
para el sector privado en Reino Unido
desde el 7,2% las cifras casi que están
completamente desfasadas porque lo piden
dicen que el aumento es muy bajo compa
inflación de Reino Unido que en
diciembre fue el 10,5% y en octubre
alcanzó el máximo en 40 años con el
11,1% anual dicen también que Amazon
Paga 10 millones muy poco sobre los 200
millones de libras que recibe de sus
ganancias dicen ellos que con base en
esto podían también incrementar Amazon
prioriza a los trabajadores de Estados
Unidos y están pidiendo trabajo
sostenibles para las personas Amazon por
su parte dice que el salario es
competitivo que pues no no puede subirse
más y pero pues estas son los argumentos
de los trabajadores escuchemos
estos trabajadores tienen que trabajar
turnos increíblemente largos solo para
tratar de llegar a fin de mes solo para
tratar de alimentar a sus familias
tenemos que ser mejores que eso Esta es
una empresa multimillonaria que genera
grandes cantidades de dinero es posible
que no paguen ningún impuesto pero sin
duda ganan mucho dinero y está en la
espalda de estos trabajadores
Y qué está pasando Juan Pablo con el
sector de las fábricas en Reino Unido es
una noticia que relaja un poco al banco
de Inglaterra porque en diciembre los
precios de producción en Reino Unido
cayeron un 0,8% Comparado con el mes
anterior esta es la máxima caída de
precios desde abril de 2020 y supera la
expectativa de los economistas que
preveían no una disminución en los
precios sino Un aumento del 0,3% en los
mismos bueno Y hoy juramentó el nuevo
Primer Ministro de Nueva Zelanda
chrishipkins que dijo sobre cuál será su
prioridad pues María Clara con la
juramentación también salieron los datos
de inflación que sigue alta desde el
trimestre anterior en Nueva Zelanda los
datos salen cada trimestre Y eso es lo
que revisaremos el panorama económico de
este país la inflación en el último
trimestre 2022 llegó al 7,2% interanual
los principales sectores que hicieron
que la inflación se mantuviera ns 7,2%
que se registró también en el trimestre
anterior fue el sector de la vivienda
con hogares y alquileres así como los
elevados precios en los alimentos y
costos de producción Aunque el índice de
precios al consumidor está por debajo
del promedio de la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económicos
el nuevo premiere dice que sigue siendo
alta frente a otros países con una
economía similar a la de Nueva Zelanda
el pib del país de 2021 Fue de más de
249 billones de dólares el dólar
neozelandés equivale a 0,64 frente al
dólar estadounidense y el desempleo se
ubicó en el 4,1% en 2021 bueno Juan
Pablo y Qué medidas se espera que tome
el Primer Ministro
dijo que no iba a comenzar a hacer
anuncios Tan pronto escuchemos
los números que hemos visto hoy subrayan
la importancia del compromiso que he
hecho en los últimos días para poner el
costo de vida y la situación económica
que enfrentamos como nuestra prioridad
número uno como gobierno solo he estado
aquí un par de horas y necesito analizar
las opciones sobre lo que podemos hacer
al respecto con mis co ministeriales
pero no voy a ser tan apresurado como
para hacer las cosas sobre la marcha
pero
Juan Pablo Cuáles son los indicadores
del día se espera que Wall Street Habla
con el anuncio de que Microsoft Tuvo una
caída en sus aplicaciones en general
vamos ahora hacia las acciones cerraron
mixtas el indicador más popular de Japón
Tuvo una leve ganancia del 0,35%
mientras el índice de referencia de la
bolsa Nacional de valores de India Tuvo
una caída del 1,25% los mercados en
China cerraron por vacaciones las bolsas
europeas siguen operando en su mayoría
con números rojos esto pese a los
anuncios del gobierno alemán que se
espera que el pib crezca un 0,2% en 2023
y con todo el panorama de la guerra en
Ucrania y los tanques Juan Pablo Gracias
por todas las noticias económicas de hoy
mañana con